2022 et la première année de mise en
oeuvre du nouveau plan de mandature 2021
2028 fruit d'un travail de partage
d'écouté de dialogue et de co
construction par les conseillers
départementaux et les services de la
collectivité
ce plan se veut évolutif pour s'adapter
aux enjeux et aux contraintes mais aussi
aux opportunités qui surviendront au fil
de cette mandature voici donc un premier
bilan de la mise en oeuvre des ambitions
portées par le département
en tant que chef de file de l'action
sociale nous avons poursuivi l'objectif
de renforcer l'accès au droit et la
prévention est de répondre à l'urgence
sociale c'est dans cette démarche que le
département a inauguré cette année la
caravane d'accès au droit et à
l'information ce nouveau service
départemental de proximité sillonnera
désormais les quartiers des hauts de
l'île pour rompre avec le non recours au
droit multifactorielle des publics
vulnérables
d'autres actions ont été conduites pour
mener à bien cette ambition le
département s'est positionné comme
précurseur dans l'expérimentation du
service public de l'insertion et de
l'emploi qu'une solution pour
décloisonner les politiques publiques
la conception du programme départemental
d'insertion 2022 2024 et
l'expérimentation du dispositif
r plus qui sera reconduit après un bilan
positif
dans ses missions dette sociale à
l'enfance le département s'est donné
pour ambition d'accompagner les parents
protéger les enfants et favoriser leur
réussite en 2021 la collectivité a porté
une attention particulière au repérage
des situations à risque et au placement
de l'enfant protéger la cellule de
recueil d'informations préoccupantes qui
gère sous l'autorité du président du
département les signalements de mineurs
en danger a été consolidée afin de
répondre plus efficacement à ses
missions la crypte 9 7 4 a vu son équipe
technique renforcée et ses actions de
prévention auprès des nombreux
partenaires multiplier afin dé
diversifier et de renforcer l'offre
d'accompagnement et d'accueil des
enfants sur le territoire de nouvelles
places ont été créées en établissements
sociaux et médico sociaux le plan de
recrutement pluriannuel des assistantes
familiales s'est poursuivie afin de
faire face aux nombreux départs à la
retraite et à l'augmentation du nombre
d'enfants confiés à l'aide sociale pour
l'enfance la collectivité a aussi
procédé à des ajustements nécessaires
sur le volet indemnités allouées aux
assistants familiaux
le vieillissement de la population
réunionnaise représente un défi pour le
département nous souhaitons protéger et
accompagner au mieux les plus
vulnérables avant de participer au mieux
vivre au sein des structures d'accueil
spécialisée le département à cette année
déployer le plan bien-être
en 2021 l'offre médico social des
personnes âgées et handicapées s'est
développé avec un plan de création de
places d'hébergement en structures
spécialisées
étalé sur cinq ans afin d'impulser une
dynamique forte d'évolution des
solutions un appel à manifestation
d'intérêt a été lancé conjointement avec
la rs pour aider les ménages défavorisés
dans leurs démarches d'amélioration de
l'habitat un plan volontariste sur cinq
ans a été votée l'an dernier dans le
cadre du plan de relance économique et
sociale de la collectivité 2021 2025
enfin le dispositif pass bien-être a été
renouvelée pendant toute la durée de la
crise sanitaire et a permis encore une
fois à de nombreux réunionnais d'accéder
à des prestations de bien-être tout en
contribuant à la relance économique du
territoire
afin d'accompagner les jeunes dans leur
parcours citoyen et leur insertion en
2021 le partenariat avec les missions
locales a été renforcée notamment avec
la mise en place de nouvelles actions
impulsées dans le cadre du plan
stratégique de lutte contre la pauvreté
avec le soutien de la collectivité la
mission locale est à bénéficier d'un
cofinancement pour mener une
expérimentation destinée à contribuer au
mieux être psychique des jeunes ayant un
parcours de vie difficile pour
développer le leadership des jeunes la
collectivité a encouragé diverses
actions citoyennes dans les collèges et
les associations concours d'éloquence
tournage d'un spot anti tabac ou encore
le concours signer collège
nous nous sommes promis de démocratiser
la culture valoriser le patrimoine et
promouvoir le sport le sport parlons-en
le plan 5000 licence a été lancée en
2022 pour garantir l'accès de tous à la
pratique d'activités sportives le
département a alloué un budget de 500
mille euros pour le financement de
licences de loisir et de compétition
nous pouvons également nous féliciter
d'avoir obtenu la labellisation terre de
jeux 2024 à la belle qui valorise les
territoires qui souhaitent mettre plus
de sport dans le quotidien de leurs
habitants s'agissant de la culture le
département a cette année encore
accompagner les acteurs de la filière
dans la poursuite de projets artistiques
et culturels
la promotion de l'identité créole elle
s'est notamment concrétisée par notre
participation active aux états généraux
du multilinguisme dans les outre mer ou
encore la publication des premiers guide
de musée en langue créole
pour accompagner les réunionnais vers
une agriculture durable et viser la
souveraineté alimentaire le département
a poursuivi la mise en oeuvre du plan
agrippé y 2030 qui prévoit de développer
l'agriculture réunionnaise en
privilégiant un modèle familial durable
et diversifiée d'autres projets ont
suivi leurs cours en ce début de
mandature le projet mais rennes qui vise
au déploiement d'un réseau hydraulique
départemental de grande envergure est
passé en maîtrise d'oeuvre en 2022 le
soutien à l'agriculture s'entreprend
toujours à travers les aides feader plus
de douze mille 700 projets ont été
financés pour plus de 420 millions
d'euros engagés permettant de passer le
seuil de dégagement d'office de crédit
feader au 1er juin 2022 2021 a également
été l'année de validation du plan bio
départementale pour faire de la ruralité
un espace majeur de l'aménagement de
notre territoire le département a
convenu de nombreux projets sur les
grands sites emblématiques l'année 2021
a été marquée par le démarrage des
travaux de reconstruction du gîte du
volcan on peut également citer les
travaux de modernisation des thermes de
cilaos qui ont permis de constater une
affluence record l'an dernier et le
début du chantier du nouveau projet
d'hôtel des termes pour un aménagement
harmonieux du territoire le département
a également apporté son soutien aux 24
communes à travers la mise en oeuvre du
pacte de solidarité territoriale
deuxième génération
afin de répondre à cette ambition la
collectivité a poursuivi son action en
matière de maîtrise de l'énergie et de
production d'énergies renouvelables
s'agissant du volet hydraulique une
expérimentation de pompes innovante sans
électricité a été menée afin d'évaluer
l'adéquation à la performance de ce type
de matériel en vue d'un déploiement
ultérieur plus large sur le territoire
la collectivité a adopté le plan
départemental de transition écologique
et solidaire et à déployer le plan un
million d'arbres mais son engagement en
faveur de l'environnement ne s'arrête
pas là preuve en est l'adoption du plan
interne de prévention et de gestion des
déchets et d'un plan de mobilité
inscrits à l'ordre du jour de cette
séance plénière
dans le but d'accroître les échanges
d'excellence et d' expertise sous le
signe de la francophonie la collectivité
poursuit le programme de formation des
élus et cadres comoriens avec un
cofinancement du ministère français des
affaires étrangères noko finances ont
également des missions de volontariat de
solidarité internationale à madagascar
aux comores aux seychelles en tanzanie
et en inde pour contribuer à favoriser
la mobilité de la jeunesse réunionnaise
à l'international le renforcement des
liens entre les populations de l'océan
indien c'est également opéré à travers
l'aide d'urgence à madagascar après le
passage de batz hirai ou encore
l'accueil de la délégation venue de
mayotte
améliorer notre efficacité au profit de
nos publics tel est le principal
objectif de la modernisation de l'action
publique pour réduire nos délais de
réponse nous avons démarré dès chantier
d'optimisation de nos processus
l'accueil premier contact du public avec
le département fait l'objet d'une
attention particulière dans les maisons
départementales les demandes d'usagers
sont désormais recensés il ya un outil
numérique permettant ainsi de compléter
le diagnostic des services d'accueil en
cours de réalisation cet accueil fait
également l'objet d'une expérimentation
dans le cadre du laboratoire
d'innovation publics pour développer la
démocratie participative et rapprocher
les citoyens de l'action publique le
département approuvent aujourd'hui le
cadre d'intervention de son premier
budget participatif
enfin le plan de mandature est un plan
agile qui doit faire l'objet
d'évaluation annuelle pour permettre les
adaptations nécessaires au fil du temps
pour cela la mise en place actuelle d'un
outil de pilotage permettra aux élus et
services de disposer d'une première
évaluation du plan dès le mois de
septembre préalablement à la préparation
des orientations budgétaires
les actions présentées ici ne sont qu'un
aperçu de tout le travail accompli grâce
à la solidarité de tous les agents
pendant cette première année de mise en
oeuvre du nouveau plan de mandature 2021